new images are flooding out of comic-con
for awesome superhero related movies
that are coming out very soon and I'm
going to talk about a few of the ones
that have come out recently in the past
few days you guys have been requesting
me to talk about and really quick I know
I do get some messages from time to time
from people who are like why are you
making videos about these little
pictures they're so incidental why are
you focusing that much time on just a
picture such a picture well I understand
where you're coming from but at the same
time I don't because you've never seen
my inbox my inbox currently is flooded
with please talk about Wonder Woman so
because you guys are my viewers I'm
gonna do that let's talk about the new
image released of gal gadot as Wonder
Woman as well as a new picture of
batfleck so just today they released
this picture of Wonder Woman as well as
the invisible jet it's back there I mean
you can't see it I can see it it's back
there probably I asked you guys what
your opinion was on my twitter and my
facebook and the majority of people
think it's pretty cool there are a few
complaints but for the most part I have
to agree with the fact that it looks
pretty cool and I was very skeptical
about this because Wonder Woman was this
humongously strong woman that honestly
is gonna be a little bit over
exaggerated in a comic and you can't
really recreate that in real life unless
you get a bodybuilder woman to portray
her which would be very distracting
another thing that would be very
distracting is if this suit was overly
sexualized or too sexy you know looking
like a stripper outfit like a dozen some
of the comics and gratefully this suit
does not look that way to me it actually
looks like it could protect her it
doesn't look like hey look my body I'm a
sexy woman and I hope you pick up this
comic book because you're a 13 year old
boy it actually looks like something
that might actually be good in a battle
and is it just me or is that the lasso
of truth hanging on her belt I picture a
scene where she whips it around Batman's
neck and forces him to tell her what his
identity is do you guys picture that
scene too because I think that'd be
pretty cool also releases a new picture
of Ben Affleck as Batman and holy God
look at that chin my word that chin it's
amazing that chin is just it's bat chin
now at this point he is as the greatest
chin of any Batman ever just like the
full picture of his suit it looks
fantastic I am so incredibly
pleased with this suit it's perfect
honestly this might just possibly be the
best Batman suit we've had so far what
I've been trying to stress every time I
make one of these Batman V Superman
update videos is that Zack Snyder's
never been accused of making a bad
looking movie just not much depth or
anything else going on sometimes that's
really the main issues with most of his
films and all this stuff looks good
hopefully it will continue to look good
and hopefully the film will be good
hopefully the film has good writing and
good directing and good dialogue and an
awesome story and more emotion and stuff
like that that will actually make a good
movie not just a good looking movie what
do you guys thoughts on these images
comment below sound off go crazy
also my inbox has been flooded with
where do you get your t-shirts questions
where'd you get your t-shirts I got this
shirt from jack of all trades clothing
comm they're pretty cool I get a lot of
my clothes from there you can check that
out whenever you want to and now I don't
have to ask me all the time and just in
case you guys did not watch my Hercules
or guardians of the galaxy review tisk
tisk I am going to be going to LA at the
start of August I'm actually being sent
there for a press junket to interview
Sean Bean himself for the new TNT show
legends and that interview is going to
be on my channel I'm extremely excited
about that it's a great opportunity for
me and I just want to thank you guys for
always sticking with me as I continue to
make videos and I hope you continue in
the future thanks guys and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh